- Hello and welcome everyone
to today's Brilliant Minds,
Bold Questions virtual talk.
Our series spotlights high impact research
from across the academy
from computer science,
population and public health
to economics and today,
molecular microbiology.
If you are not familiar with us,
CIFAR is a global research organization
that convenes extraordinary minds
to address the most important questions
facing science and humanity.
My name is Rachel Parker.
I am Senior Director of Research at CIFAR,
and it is my distinct
pleasure to introduce you
to our two speakers for today's talk
on how do we get to net zero.
First, we have Curtis Berlinguette,
who is Professor of Chemistry
and Chemical and Biological Engineering
at the University of British Columbia.
Curtis leads an interdisciplinary
team seeking ways
to discover and scale disruptive
clean energy materials.
His academic group advances
fundamental science
and a range of clean energy applications,
including CO2 utilization
and advanced nuclear fusion.
Also joining us is Yogesh
Surendranath or Yogi,
who is an Associate
Professor of Chemistry at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology.
Research in Yogi's group aims
to use renewable electricity
to rearrange chemical bonds
by controlling interfacial reactivity
at the molecular level.
The chemistry of these
interfaces is at the heart
of nearly all contemporary challenges
in renewable energy
storage and utilization
in a wide variety of technologies.
Addressing this challenge
is essential for enabling
a low carbon energy future.
Today's session will last
approximately 30 minutes.
I will start the session with a question
before inviting our speakers
to interview one another
for about 20 to 25 minutes.
And after this, I'll open the
floor back up to questions
from participants online.
If you, as an online audience
member, have a question,
you can use the Q&A function to submit it.
We ask that you not use the chat function
to submit questions.
Lastly, the session is being recorded
and will be available on
the CIFAR website next week.
Welcome Curtis and Yogi.
So to get us started,
we know that CO2 and
other heat trapping gases
are the main drivers of global warming.
To avoid the worst
consequences of global warming,
we'll need to reach net
zero in our carbon footprint
in less than 30 years.
Obviously this is no simple task.
What is missing from the
current research agenda
that can aim to address the carbon threat?
- Thanks, Rachel.
And good morning, good
afternoon, everyone.
So Yogi, so chemists worldwide
are working to design catalysts that
will speed up critical
chemical reactions needed
to convert renewable resources,
such as biomass into fuels and chemicals.
So Yogi, what is a catalyst
and what does it do?
- Thanks Curtis.
So catalysis and catalysis
science is really
at the heart of many of
the challenges we face
in decarbonizing the global energy system
and what a catalyst really
is, is a material, a molecule,
it can be many things, but it's
function is what's critical.
It serves the role of neither
being produced nor consumed
in the the overarching chemical reaction,
but it serves a function
essentially chaperoning
the reactance towards
products across a low energy,
high efficiency pathway.
And in doing so, it allows us
to carry out chemical reactions
much faster than without a catalyst.
And in the cases of
energy driven processes
with much lower energy
input than we would need,
if we didn't have a catalyst
or if we didn't have the
most optimal catalyst.
The other thing a catalyst really does,
it's equally important, is it
defines what the products are.
It sets whether you turn a
reactant into one product
or 50,000 products
and how you choose which product you get
is critical to how much
energy you put in the process,
how useful and valuable that product is.
And indeed, if you think
about the conversion of CO2
into fuels or chemicals,
you'd want the optimal distribution
of those fuel molecules
or chemical molecules
for a given application,
whether it be in the aviation sector
or in other areas of our economy.
But you don't want molecules
that would be deleterious
to their endpoint use.
And so catalysis plays this essential role
in guiding reactions
towards one desired product
over another,
thereby minimizing the costs
that would otherwise accrue
from needing to do energy
intensive separations
of the products afterwards
and in allowing us to access the materials
that we would like with the
least amount of energy input.
So let me turn the floor
back over to Curtis actually.
So, you know, I'm a
catalysis science person,
but one thing that we've
actually learned over the years
is that the discovery of new
materials, new catalysts,
new technologies for a lot
of these grand de-carbonization challenges
can take quite a long time.
And many times we don't
even know the principles
or we don't know the unknown unknowns
on that journey towards new technologies.
Curtis, I would like to turn
the floor over to you and ask,
what is your research group doing really
to shorten that development timescale?
- Yeah.
And shortening that development timescale
is critical for us in terms
of solving the CO2 problem,
because we don't have
a lot of time available
to come up with with big solutions.
And so one of the things our
group is very motivated by
are recent advances in
robotics and automation,
big data and machine learning.
And what we're doing is
we're taking all three
of these aspects and we're bringing them
into the research laboratory.
So that way we can
actually make smart robots,
to make self-driving robots,
that actually will help us make decisions
on the experiments that
we're making in the lab.
And our mission here is to be
able to accelerate the time
it takes to take a new
discovery in the laboratory,
out in the marketplace,
by at least tenfold.
And one of the challenges
that we have with hard tech,
commercializing hard tech
and taking things out of the laboratory
and into the marketplace,
is that it tends to take over a decade,
often a couple of decades or more.
And when we look into the future,
we want to have some CO2
technologies that are out
in the market within the next decade,
not two decades from now.
And so what we're trying to
do is be able to leverage all
of these recent advances in automation,
to be able to help us do that,
to help the researchers in
the lab collect more data,
to collect higher fidelity data,
and to also to be able to use algorithms
to help process the data
that's actually being created
and assimilate that information
into discovering new
materials, making new devices
and advancing those devices
and putting them into practice.
You know, when we look back
over the course of history,
if we look at fuel cells, for example,
it's taken three plus
decades for fuel cells
to start hitting the market,
which they're really just
doing over the last few years.
And we really think that
we can learn information
from that particular sector
and help us accelerate
the development of these
different technologies.
So this is something that
very much motivates us.
- Curtis, if I can follow
up on that actually,
in the domain of using automation,
some of the challenges in
deploying green technologies
is the challenges, the
unforeseen challenges,
that occur when they get scaled up.
Talk to me about how
automation, if you feel it can,
can even accelerate and perhaps
foreshadow those challenges
that may occur upon the
long term deployment
or the scale up of certain technologies.
- Yeah.
So I think automation can
help at various stages
in the development process.
In the lab it can help
us find new materials.
We can then potentially use robotics
to take those new materials
and to implement them into devices.
And that process, that
step of actually taking
a brand new material and
putting it into a device,
that is a slow step in the lab today.
Testing those materials in that device
is a slow step for today.
And so being able to bring in automation
and particularly new algorithms
that are coming online
to help us process data
that are coming out of that,
we're really confident that
we can shorten the timelines
from getting, from the lab
again to a commercial product.
One of the challenges that we
have as researchers though,
is that it's really difficult
to put automation into action.
Typically, what happens
is you have to buy a robot
from a vendor, but most
of these robots that
are commercially available
can only do one specific task.
And most of the research that takes place
in the university environment
requires a number of
different tasks, okay.
So human have the incredible dexterity
and this ability to pivot on the fly,
to do different experiments,
to get creative and shift and
so one of the core features
of our program is we're
actually really trying
to promote this concept
of flexible automation,
making robots that can
change on the fly with you,
change with the experiment and
evolve with the experiments
as you're understanding the
experiments start to change.
And that way you're not having to build
a brand new robot for every single step.
'Cause if you have to
build a brand new robot
for every single step,
that's going to be slower than
the current process today.
So it's definitely not a solved problem.
And there's several of us in
around the world right now
that are really trying to
more rapidly bring robotics
into the laboratory so that
way we can use automation
and machine learning
to its fullest extent.
So Yogi, I know, you know,
you work on something
that I'm super interested in
and that's really the chemistry
at the interface, right?
That's really where
all the action happens.
And so can you explain to everyone here
and how something so
seemingly small in scale,
really just those atoms that
exist right at the interface
has such a huge impact on the properties
of the devices that we're making
for really making renewable
and capturing renewable energy
and converting that renewable energy
into useful forms of energy.
- Yeah. Yeah. Thanks Curtis.
The, you know, I've been
captivated in that problem
of interfaces and interfacial
reactivity for a long time,
really the entirety of
my independent career.
And I got drawn to that by sort of,
a kind of a key point really,
is that one way I like
to think about it is,
that a lot of the
processes we want to drive
involve moving things against
thermodynamic gradients,
moving, essentially rolling balls uphill.
We want to take energy poor molecules,
turn them into energy rich molecules
and electricity is a powerful force
for actually driving
those reactions uphill.
And you can ask,
so where does electricity,
carried in sort of macroscopic
wires meet molecules
and their inner conversion reactions.
It turns out where that
occurs is at interfaces.
It occurs in the interfaces
of our cell phone batteries.
It occurs in the interfaces of a fuel cell
or electrolyzer that's
making renewable hydrogen
or converting CO2 to a fuel.
And the interesting thing
that's so fascinating actually,
is that despite the critical
role that these interfac
and the reason that's so critical is
because that's where the
electrons that come in
via charge separation in a circuit,
meet the molecules that they're
going to do reactions on.
And so the properties of that
interface are so critical
to defining how catalytic
transformations occur
and particularly energy
relevant transformations occur.
What has gratified us
and really been
interesting to think about,
and this is why I think, you know,
CIFAR's and their support
has been been central
to this really is that the problems
around how we think about interfaces,
despite how important they are,
the basic understanding
of how they function,
how they rearrange, how they degrade,
how they operate under
realistic conditions
is still very much in its infancy.
We're trying to drive a Ferrari
without knowing how the parts
are put together in a sense,
in most of the devices that we make.
And so you can imagine
that when your cell phone battery dies,
that becomes a more of a phenomenology
than something that we
can look up in a textbook
and be like, ah, that's the reason
that this cell phone battery
degraded after this amount
of cycle number, right?
We are still at a place
where we get those pieces
of information from the laboratory
and we're sort of left
scratching our heads,
wondering why that is.
And that's because at an atomistic level,
we don't have a robust understanding
of how interfaces work.
They provide these exotic environments.
One of the things that makes
me so amazed is, you know,
the interfaces they generate
separations of charge
that generates some of the
largest known electric fields
in chemistry.
You get enormous electric
fields on the order of tens
of mega volts per centimeter,
over the length scale of just a few atoms.
And this allows you to
literally rip bonds apart.
And we've been doing this in electro,
we've been ripping some of
the strongest bonds apart,
the bonds between
aluminum and oxygen apart
to make the aluminum that
we put in all of our planes.
And we still don't even for that process,
know how that works.
And so a lot of what
my group really studies
is how does at an atomistic level,
how can you use these enormous
electric fields that happen
at an interface to drive reactions
against their native
propensity to go downhill,
along a free energy gradient?
So we want to take energy poor molecules,
turn them in energy rich molecules,
and the way we use it,
the way we do that is by
taking interfacial fields
to literally rearrange those bonds.
And we try to unpack those mechanisms
and then use that to
then design new materials
in a systematic way.
- Is the challenge you're faced with today
is that we just don't
have the tools available
to really dial into that
particular region of study?
- Yeah.
So the issue with
interfaces is this a needle
in the haystack problem, right?
Because you have the
bulk of your electrode
or your material,
and you have the bulk of your
solution or your electrolyte.
And even though those
are 99.9% of the system,
it's that 0.01% right at the interface
that defines whether the
whole thing works or not.
And so we really have a paucity of tools,
if you will, we don't have the microscopes
to hone in on what's
happening in the interface
without the sort of clutter
and background and fog
of all the stuff that's
happening in solution
or in the solid.
And that's really a core of the challenge.
And one of the ways we've
really addressed that challenge
is not necessarily by
making a better microscope,
but by making better
ways to implant something
very precisely at the interface
and asking from that how does
that lead to specific effects?
So, in a way, we don't
try to measure the needle
in the haystack,
we try to implant a very
shiny needle in the haystack
that can serve as a beacon for us
to understand that
outside of all of the fog.
- Very cool.
- So speaking of an
interfacial problem, you know,
one of the interfacial problems
that both of us have a lot of interest in
is converting CO2 into
valuable chemicals and fuels.
So talk to me about that, Curtis.
What can we convert CO2 into?
What are the useful things
that we can make it into?
And how would we go about doing that?
- Right, just to calibrate everybody,
so Yogi and I are very much
interested in finding ways
that we can use clean,
renewable electricity
to drive these transformations
of CO2 into something useful.
And ultimately what the
commercial device will look like
is like a water electrolyzer.
So a CO2 electrolyzer, think
of it just as a big box
where you've got CO2 going in one side
with water and electricity.
And then on the other side,
you're going to have like a byproduct
and you're going to have
some chemical byproduct
containing that upgraded carbon,
so that CO2 has been upgraded
to some carbon species.
And the beautiful thing
about CO2 electric chemistry
is that there are a wide range of products
that you can make within that electrolyzer
by applying really the same
amount of electrical energy.
The choice of product that
comes out on the other end,
all comes back to the
identity of that catalyst
that you put into the electrolyzer.
And this is, gets back to
the first point that Yogi
was making earlier today,
the catalysts play such a
critical role in dictating
how that CO2 gets converted
into something useful.
So what are some of the products that
could potentially be coming
out on the other end?
One of the products that we
like to make is carbon monoxide.
Okay, so no one wants to go to the store
to buy carbon monoxide, I get it.
But you can take that carbon
monoxide in a chemical plant,
and it ends up being a
very useful building block.
It's a very reactive
species, and you can convert,
you can polymerize that carbon monoxide
into useful plastics or other
carbon-containing materials.
You can actually mix it with hydrogen,
which is actually a
byproduct that comes out of
the electrolyzer.
So you're effectively making syn-gas.
And so there's an opportunity there
to actually just use that
product that's coming out of
the other end, and actually
do further processing
to convert it into fuels
that can then be used.
There's a range of other
products that you make, you know,
acidic acid, formic acid, ethylene.
And there are now thousands of
researchers around the world
that are all trying to really
manipulate the catalyst
and the engineering of the electrolyzer
to be able to make these
different products.
But one of the things that
we've been really thinking a lot
about in our group is just like,
if you could actually make
all of those carbon products
that, like all the plastics in the world,
everything outside of liquid fuels,
what, you know, how much
CO2 are you actually going
to be fixing?
And so this is actually
forced us down this path
of really thinking through
what type of product should
we be converting CO2 into?
And this exercise has
actually helped us converge
on really focusing on building materials.
We really are incented to
try to figure out how can we
take CO2 from the atmosphere
and convert it into cement, for example.
And why we like cement
is that if you're going
to take that CO2, convert it into cement,
that cement is going to be fixed in place
for several decades.
And that's one of the
other things that we have
to take into consideration in the choice
of the CO2 products that we're making,
because if we're just going to utilize
that carbon based product and combust it
and return that CO2 back to the atmosphere
in a very short timeframe,
we're not necessarily solving the problem.
And so this is just another
challenge that we have
in the CO2 sciences is
figuring out what product
are we going to make in which
we're fixing that carbon
for a really long time period.
And so building materials seems like one
of those candidate materials
that not a lot of people
are looking at right now,
people are starting to look at that.
But we see that as a huge opportunity
for our field moving forward.
- Curtis, a corollary to that is is CO2
is only at about 400 PPM in the atmosphere
though rising fast, but that
doesn't seem very concentrated.
How do we get the CO2 that
we would use to convert
into all of these valuable products?
- Right.
So we're really relying
on different technologies
to capture that CO2 either from air
or from right from the flue
stack of different plants.
But ultimately we need
to solve this problem,
but really probably by taking that CO2
from the atmosphere in some way.
And there are quite a different,
quite a few different
ways of doing that today
and lots of different
technologies that are out there.
And I really think that what's important
for our community is to make sure that
our CO2 utilization community
is really thinking about
how that CO2 is captured.
So that the challenge that
the CO2 capture folks have
is that if they have a technology
that captures CO2 readily,
that same material that captured the CO2
is not likely going to want to
give up that CO2 very easily.
And so, as a result, there's
an energy penalty associated
with releasing that CO2
so then you can either store it
or feed it into your CO2
electrolyzer down the road.
And so finding something that
captures that CO2 very quickly
and at scale,
and then is willing to release that CO2
with as little energy as possible
is really the grand challenge
for us in the CO2 sciences.
And something that our CIFAR
program is very motivated to do
is actually look at coupling
these two communities
of CO2 capture and CO2 utilization
and bring our different communities
and our different technologies together
to see if we can do
everything in one single unit
instead of operating as silos,
which really is how we've,
the two communities have been operating
over the last few years.
So Yogi, I mentioned catalysts,
can you mention a little bit more about
what the specific properties of catalyst
that you're looking at
and how specifically you
can tune that performance?
- Yeah, sure.
So catalyst design is a
kind of a grand challenge
that as I think Curtis
and I both talked about
pervades a lot of these
challenges in green technologies
and CO2 utilization.
What we really look for in catalysis
is something that really
will accelerate the reaction
as much as possible.
That's sort of the rate at
which the catalyst turns over
the reacting into product.
Another feature we really
look for in a catalyst
is something that will
form a single product
over many products.
That's the question of selectivity.
The first one is a question of efficiency
or sort of performance of the catalyst.
Second one is related to the
selectivity of the catalyst.
And then there's a very key
and often overlooked parameter.
That's equally important
in catalysis science,
which is the durability of your catalyst.
Whether its ability to
catalyze that reaction
and its ability to it selectively
to a single value added product,
does that remain the same over time
or after running it a
hundred or a thousand hours,
does it then degrade
and is no longer useful?
Of course you can imagine
that a catalyst needs
to have a durability on
the order of the lifetime
of the types of devices
we anticipate deploying
for CO2 utilization which we would imagine
are on the order of many decades, right?
So in the same way that the Curtis
and I have a shared interest
in looking at catalyst
for CO2 conversion while
the community has made,
I would say really amazing
progress over the last decade
or so in developing new catalysts,
new understanding of
their mechanisms of action
and new ways of controlling
their selectivity
and efficiency.
We still haven't yet gotten a good sense
for whether those catalysts
will have the requisite
durability to be able to make it
in a device for two decades
or three decades, right.
And in many cases, it's
not easy to test that
in the laboratory.
And oftentimes it's not easy
because in a real operating system,
your catalyst may be
exposed to tiny amounts
of foreign materials or poisons
or other species that you
don't often simulate for
in the laboratory.
And so that remains just a
very much an open challenge
for catalysis science,
but critical to the deployment
of these technologies.
- So a follow up question on that,
if I could just interject here as well,
and share what the biggest barriers are
for the adoption of green technology
from a commercialization standpoint.
- You know, Yogi just
touched on the big one
and that is proving out
technology can survive
in the real world for several years,
if not a decade or more.
And we simply don't have
a lot of tools available
to us that allow us to do
the accelerated testing
that is reliable enough,
that gives the people
that are going to go out
and commercialize these technologies,
the comfort to both invest in it
and to be able to introduce
those products into their plan.
So durability, I would
say is probably the,
it is the one step that takes the longest
to prove out 'cause ultimately you have
to run the experiment
before a lot of people
will invest and use it.
And so coming up with
new ways to really try
to understand how we can get information
on how a system will behave
years into the future,
is it needs to become
a more important area
of science and engineering
for the community.
I would say that the other limitation
until the last couple of years, of course,
is really the capital
available to be able to go out
and pursue many of these technologies.
There was a lot of money that got injected
into clean tech in the
early part of the century,
and after 2008, a lot of
that capital disappeared
and clean tech became a very bad word
in the investment world.
What's happening today is now people
are a lot more sensitive
to global warming.
They're impacted directly
by global warming
and now everybody's realizing
that we really do need
to invest in this.
And so I'm actually really excited
to see how much capital is
coming back into looking
at clean energy technologies
and carbon capture, carbon utilization.
These are some very hot areas
for investment right now,
and this is really how you drive change.
So I'm really excited to see the interest
and support that we're getting
from beyond the science community
that we actually weren't getting
even a couple of years ago.
- That seems to me like a
perfect ending point for today.
Let's end on a note of
optimism for the future
and hope that we've captured
people's imagination
and interest in the subject.
And we wish you all the best.
And thank you so much, Yogi and Curtis,
for taking your time
to talk with us today,
we look forward to watching
your program in future
and thanks everybody for
watching it from home.
- Thank you.
- Thank you. Thank you to CIFAR.
(calm music)